- What's up, y'all?
I'm here with Sarah Chalke,
and we've got an audience
full of single ladies.
And we are what?
(cheering)
Sipping sangria and we
are celebrating all our
(cheering)
that's a right.
Our next guest is one of the
funniest single ladies we know.
She is the host of the
"Two Funny Mamas" podcast,
she's a Weight Watchers ambassador
and you can see her co-host
"Daily Pop" weekdays on E!
Take a look.
- You know what?
I was just confused.
See, I'm a big fan of The Weekend.
I love him.
- Who said that?
- Huh? I was, when he
went into the gold room,
the gold room got me dizzy
and he was looking around
and everybody had on these little masks.
Look, see.
That right there, right
there I'm confused.
(laughs)
I was like, that camera angle's
going to be the death of me.
I was dizzy!
(laughing)
- Alright everybody please
welcome Kym Whitley.
(upbeat music)
- Well cheers.
- Cheers.
- I know we still can't
get near each other,
but you look fantastic!
- Well, thank you girl.
That Weight Watchers,
WW been working, child.
- I should look into it.
- [Kym] Hey y'all!
- Your hair looks awesome.
You look so great.
- You look beautiful too.
Look at you.
- [Kelly] I went with like with
a little grunge vibe today.
Say hi to Sarah as well.
- Hi Sarah.
How are you doing?
Can she see me?
This is so weird.
(laughing)
- Oh my god.
- This is so weird.
This is, so this is my
first time on a real set.
- In a while.
- You know, we were doing it virtually,
so I didn't get to see you in person.
You look, you look, just as cute.
Look at you at home.
- [Kelly] Oh, thank you.
I was like, I was so excited.
I walked in, my stylist had this dress.
I was like, you love me.
I was like, I can, this,
this has some room.
'Cause I'm drinking today, so.
- That is so me.
How are the kids?
I'm just going to ask
how are the children?
- [Kelly] So good, honestly.
- [Kym] Good, good.
- Yeah, honestly, I don't know
what's been happening in the last,
they now have got to start
going back to school,
but, like literally,
like their personality,
they're not mean anymore.
I feel like they got mean
a little in the pandemic.
- [Kym] They did.
- And, you know, rightly so.
You were stuck,
but like they're nice now.
- [Kym] Yes, they are
because they've gotten
used to being in prison.
(laughing)
- They're out now, though.
So wait, we're celebrating
being single today.
So what, what do you think the
best part of being single is?
- [Kym] Oh my God.
For me, the best part of being single is
I don't have to bathe for like three days.
(laughing)
- We are so similar.
- [Kym] Yes, oh my God.
- My hair, I could like tune a car
with the amount of oil that comes in here.
- [Kym] Absolutely, the amount of hair,
like I can just become
Sasquatch, and don't,
who cares?
(laughing)
Like, just don't, don't do a close-up.
Like, you don't have to de-wax.
I think that is the best
part of being single for me.
You don't have to really answer to what,
you don't have to,
you can just be you.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And just relax.
- It's freeing.
- It is absolutely freeing.
Like, if I want to be a
man, I'm a man at home.
(laughing)
Absolutely, my twin brother.
- I love it.
(laughing)
I have that as well.
Well, we talked about this before,
'cause dating in COVID was a little odd,
but has it gotten any better?
- Has it got, it,
you know, it has not gotten any better
because, I'm sorry.
(laughing)
The truth is this.
If you want to date a man now,
you got to get tested for me.
(laughing)
Oh no, you gonna get tested.
I, I, I, you gotta get tested,
all you're little STDs,
forget the STDs.
Get that Covid test.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I like it.
- I'll take a STD,
I don't want my lungs blowing up.
- I'd like a full panel.
I'd like a full panel done.
- [Kym] Full panel,
give me a full panel, all the tests.
- [Kelly] I want to know
what I'm working with.
(laughing)
That's amazing.
That's true though.
- Isn't it true?
- It's funny, but it's true.
It's like, don't be
bringing that over here.
- No, don't bring that.
My son has asthma, honey.
- [Kelly] Yeah, no.
Yeah. That's nothing to mess around with.
What, what's the most ridiculous line
that a guy has used on you?
- [Kym] Oh, first of all, let me tell you,
thank you.
I will come to your show anytime.
- [Kelly] It's so good,
- This is fantastic.
- it's dangerous.
Someone is gonna be holding the hair.
- I'm gonna be doing a table dance.
What's the weight limit?
Make sure that's sturdy.
(laughing)
- It's my show,
so it'll hold anyone.
( laughing)
- [Kym] You got that one,
I got this one.
- Just in case I get up there.
(laughing)
We make em' sturdy.
- Okay, the most ridiculous.
There's, there's so many things.
I'm used to men saying,
can I borrow some money
and I'll pay you back?
- [Kelly] Oh!
- I have, I have men saying stuff like,
Oh, you must be tired.
Oh, 'cause you've been walking
through my dreams all day.
- Oh, no.
- [Kym] You know that
one, that cracks me up.
But I always gotta comeback, honey.
Cause I'm like, did you buy my shoes?
Cause if you didn't, I wasn't
walking through your dreams.
No.
(laughing)
- Yeah, I legit,
if somebody ever said
that to me, I'd be like,
thank you for just showing
me the weeds in the garden.
I will move along.
- [Kym] That's it.
There's so many, you know,
I had this one man after a comedy show.
I had this one man show up after the show
and just give me a whole bunch of money.
Like he was making it rain, you know,
like I was a stripper or something.
(laughing)
I was appalled.
You know, and I picked up all the money,
I put it in my bag.
- [Kelly] Exactly.
- And I said,
I am not that type of girl,
(laughing)
but I went on about my way, with my stash.
- But I will take this.
- I will take this.
I was like, thank you.
Thank you so much.
I said, this is tides and
offerings for the church.
- [Kelly] Tides and offerings.
(laughing)
- This was the 10%
- [Kelly] 10%.
- for the Lord, for the Lord.
- Have you, Sarah, what,
have you ever had any
horrible lines used on you?
- I had one really weird experience
where I was just starting
going to university all with a new group
of friends and we were at
a freedom for Tibet rally,
and this guy came over to me
and he was like, I hated you.
You were like way the worst Becky.
I really liked the other Becky better.
And then he walked away,
and I'm like just trying to
blend in with my new friends.
And then he came back about
an hour later and he goes,
I just want to really apologize.
I've just really always
wanted to yell at an actor.
So I'm super sorry.
And then he walked away.
My friend was like, I think
he's actually hitting on you.
And I was like, well, that's
a very unique strategy.
(laughing)
- What?
- [Kym] They try to knock you down,
so they can bring you back up.
- [Kelly] Yeah. That's emotional abuse.
That's what that is.
- [Kym] That is emotional abuse.
- That's, that's gas lighting.
That's all the things that are bad.
Stay away.
So wait, let's talk about,
let's talk about your
show though, "Daily Pop."
So it deals with
celebrities and pop culture.
So what was like your
wildest celebrity encounter?
- [Kym] Okay.
It was at an award show
called the Neighborhood Awards
and Steve Harvey was giving it,
and I was on the stage and I
thought I was going to be funny
and say something to Shemar Moore,
flirting because you know my mouth.
I was like, ha ha,
Shemar Moore, I see you in the front row.
Saying all that.
He gets out of his seat,
and he starts to come up the steps,
and I'm like, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I didn't call you up here.
Wait, wait, wait.
This is security, security.
Don't come up here.
Shemar Moore comes up,
and this is the first thing,
especially with a big girl,
all men think they can just pick you up.
That's the first thing they want to do.
And I'm looking at little
Shemar, little skinny ass,
I was like, don't you do it.
Don't you embarrass yourself.
Don't you pick up this.
I'm solid.
So he comes up, and he looks at me,
and I was like, Oh my God.
And I whispered in his ear,
and he came up close, and
I said, don't pick me up.
Please don't pick me up.
He was like, I'm not going to pick you up.
And he grabs my face,
and he sticks his tongue down my throat.
- [Kelly] No.
- [Kym] I don't even
know my body can, yes!
Look at that right there.
- You are one powerful manifestor.
You said it, and it happened.
- Wait a minute, I'm going
to call him and get him
COVID tested.
(laughing)
- Everybody be sure to
watch Kym on "Daily Pop"
weekdays on E!